when the model started coming out I was
watching things just get automated away
and I feel this myself was like where's
the mo with companies with AI the only
multi left community and if there
businesses we're going to hire humans to
do telling then we're going to put the
tellings in the modules that's already
obsolete so check's an easy one because
they're just a whole bunch and this was
like right when the thing they 50% of
the users left because they're like oh I
can go on CH for free and get a better
telling I remember like two ideas coming
together put do
first second was don't put Community
second put Community First well I'm
going to start with do then I'm going to
start with how can the community improve
it and then I'll figure out what
contents needed because I don't want to
make content because it'll be irrelevant
next
week